- Good afternoon.
Welcome to the 31st
Kuznets Memorial Lecture
organized by "Economic Growth Center."
I'm Rohini Pande, a professor
in economics department
and the director of EGC.
The Kuznets Memorial
Lecture is an annual lecture
on issues of economic development
given by a prominent economist
in memory of Simon Kuznets,
who helped found the Economic
Growth Center in 1961.
Professor Kuznets went
on to win the Nobel prize
for I quote, "Empirically
Founded Interpretation
of Economic Growth," which has
led to new and deepen insight
into the economic and social structure
and processes of development.
Today, as Yale's hub
for economics research
and teaching on issues
concerning lower income economies
and advancement of their populations,
we continue to advance this agenda.
Simon Kuznets studied economics
at the Kharkiv National
Economic University in Ukraine
before migrating to the United States.
Like this lecture series,
the school by Kuznets
began his studies now bears his name,
the Simon Kuznets Kharkiv
National University of Economics.
The fact that that city is under attack
and the school has been
bombed is a stark symbol
of how politics touches
every aspect of life
and how economics cannot be understood
without taking power into account.
This year, the lecture will presented
by professor Leonard Wantchekon,
a scholar whose life in
research have contributed
to our understanding the intersections
between economics and political power.
An accomplished scholar in many fields,
professor Wantchekon research spans areas
such as clientelism and State Capture,
resource course and democratization,
where he has implemented field experiments
with politicians competing
in real elections
to investigate voting behavior
and election outcomes.
Since 2015, he has been
a professor of politics
and international affairs
at Princeton University,
as well as an Associate
Faculty in Economics.
And he has previously
served as a professor
in New York University
and at Yale University
where he was also an EGC affiliate.
Professor Wantchekon
has also been a leader
in diversifying the economics profession.
In 2014, he opened "African
School of Economics"
in Benin with a mission
to produce world renowned,
social scientists and economical
leaders on the continent.
EAC has broadened the pipeline
of young African scholars
entering leading graduate
programs, Economics,
and Political Science,
and we are very grateful
for Leonard a leadership here.
Today's lecture and the
related conference tomorrow
organized by professor Van
Chi Kun and Nathan Cannon
of the University of
Houston, focus on the subject
of Political Distortions
and Economic Development.
Bally just before we start some logistics,
we will record this evening's
program and post it online
for public view.
So please be aware that
your your presence here
is in effect permission
to broadcast your image
and any questions you ask in the Q and A.
I'd also like to welcome
those who are joining us
via the zoom webinar.
Please feel free to submit
questions on the zoom chat
for the Q and A.
And finally, I would like
to thank the EGC staff
and students have really helped
us make this event happen.
A big thank you to Vestal
McIntyre and Bomi Okuyiga
on communications and Deanna Ford Benking,
especially Noel Sardalla
for all that hard work.
Now please join me in
welcoming professor Wantchekon
into the stage, Leonard.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.
Okay, so thanks Rohini for
such a generous introduction.
Today I'll be speaking
about Political Distortion
and Economic Development.
It's a topic that I was
interested in studying
and doing something about
since I was in middle school.
This is a picture of me on the
left as a political activist,
trying to do something
about Political Distortion,
autocracy in the name in the eighties.
Then later on when I started
my PhD at Northwestern,
my first paper, my first proposal
was actually about Political Mechanism
in Economic Development.
So for 30 years, I have been
waiting for the opportunity
to actually talk about
Political Distortion.
And I'm so grateful for EGC
for giving me this opportunity
and it is never late,
so you can notice that
it was Wantchekon there.
So later on, I changed the
spelling of my name to W
and you have some interesting comments
by my then advisor (indistinct),
very, very generous.
So the talk will be structured
with an introduction
to motivate the topic I'll be covering
and provide political benchmarks.
And then the empirics
of Political Distortion
on three aspect, one is
Voter-Induced Political Distortion,
like Political Distortion
that induce by relationship
between politician and
voters called Patronage
or the denomination, and
then Film-Induced Distortion,
which is under label of
Political Connections.
And then I'll talk about State Capture,
which is a more systemic, deep
form of Political Distortion.
And what I hope will be
the highlight of the talk
will be about remedies,
and I'm going to cover
several aspects of how Political
Distortion can be mitigated
with public management,
with political selection,
and then something that I
will explain to you later
that I call Public Reason,
which is how you get
the public to be engaged
in the process of policy making,
and I will provide direction
for future research.
As a way of introduction,
now recent microeconomic literature
emphasized the role of
misallocation of production factors
at the micro level.
Sorry, I think I should be yeah, sorry.
So as a way of background,
differences in living standard
across countries are large
persistence and driven by growth,
and those differences are
due to productivity gaps
in this allocation.
The key fact that will
motivate our study here
is that these disparities
in labeling capital
account for at almost 50% of differences
in income-per-capital.
So there is room for institutions
in government to play a very,
very, very important role
to get the economy to
an optimal allocation
of production factors.
So throughout the talk,
there will be some focus
on first best allocation and
distortion being a deviation
from this first best,
first best allocation
together with some political aspect.
All right, political
institutions now it's established
that they have very, very
important impact on growth
and they affect growth through
their influence on governance
and state capacity.
And it's all also political
institution and mechanism
for selection of office holders,
the many of policy decision
and the logic of enforcement
of those policies.
So there have been a
wide range of coverage
of political institutions,
particularly (indistinct)
Robinson in their 2016 book,
which associate economic
institution to prosperity
and that emerge from a balance
increase in state capacity
and this regional power.
But what is also key is
that there are whole sector
of society, without power
that need to be included.
And these sort redistribution of resources
is actually key to prosperity.
And if redistribution of resources,
redistribution in general
is key to prosperity,
then political institution
have to allow for disempowered
to act as principal.
So institution that
should be also accountable
to a need of a poor and
institution that have capacity
to meet those needs.
So, as I mentioned earlier,
there is a wide range of work
on historical institutions,
precolonial institution,
fractionalization, and
heterogenity of ethnicity
and culture that have
great impact on growth.
So that the church has provide insights
on the origin of
institutions and its effect.
But it has limited, I should
say policy implications
and sometime maybe misread
as historical determinism.
So, as (indistinct) Robinson and cohorters
have empirically established
that history may account
for at most 50% of the
development outcome.
In my own work we show that
slavery, particularly in Africa
has important long term impact
on development through trust
and interpersonal trust.
But it'll explain between
15 and 25% of variation
in trust level.
So clearly history matter,
history play an important role
in current development level,
but its account for a fraction
of the variation development outcome.
So, what is also important to note
is that there is a growing evidence
suggesting that countries
with similar level,
let's say country with similar history,
similar historical trajectories,
have a wide range of developing outcome,
not only across countries,
but even within countries.
So this convergence shows
that institutions policy
matter for development.
In fact, history can be overcome.
History is a constraint, but with policy,
with institutional design
it's effect can be mitigated.
So I have graph from a recent
paper by creman and Co-authors
showing for instance,
that we have convergence
in institution level around the world,
particularly between Africa and Asia
and Africa, the rest of the world.
So what I'm going to be
focusing on this lecture
is instead of asking whether institution
contributes to growth,
is to focus on what type of institution
are most effective for growth
and how they can be implemented.
What is your role of contractual policies
for institutional experimentation,
for instance, antitrust
laws, decentralization,
policy deliberation.
And I have been particularly inspired
by the recent experience
of China, pre 1975.
The focus was on absolutism
and cultural revolution
and communism, but now
the focus is instead
on institutional reform,
public management,
decentralization, and
policy experimentation.
So let me start by
explaining a little bit,
what is Political Distortion?
So when a political system and use choices
that are suboptimal in terms of welfare
and development outcome,
they affect human capital
formation innovation.
They affect capital investment
through regulatory
policies and procurement.
They affect spatial
friction, misallocation,
and infrastructure
spending, market distortion.
And those distort, Political
Distortion can be complementary
to other distortion and
development and macroeconomy
like transportation
information and market access.
So what we need to do
is to provide benchmark,
if you look at benchmark,
that will tell us something
about what the optimal
public investment should be.
What is the optimal
institution's arrangement
to promote innovation
and technological change.
And then we will present the
departure from those me mark,
as Political Distortion.
We will document how the
distortion leads to misallocation
of public investment and State Capture.
And then later on, as I mentioned earlier,
we are going to discuss
what policies can alleviate
those distortion.
So for interest of time,
I'm going to focus on two benchmark model.
One is by Barro 1990, that
constructed growth model
that included public services
as a productive input
for private producers.
So it's a model of governments,
the role of governments
in the economy particularly
in terms of public investment.
And the focus is on
publicly provided goods
that are subject to
congestion, which are rival,
but to some extent
non-excludable like highways,
water installation, courts and so on.
And an individual decision
to explain its own capital
in that model, enhanced outputs,
congest the facility
available to other producers.
So the growth rate in
that economy is suboptimal
and there is a room for
income tax over lump-sum tax
to get to the optimal level
of allocation in that economy.
So what we draw from this is
that when for instance taxes
or investment that target co-ethnics
or target interest groups
is a clear distortion
from what is the optimal
public investment.
So the other model focusing on innovation
and market competition gives
by Aghion and cohorters
give a Schumpeterian growth
model in which firms innovate
until they succeed, then
block others, market entry.
The setup is one in
which the final output Yt
is equal to 80 the technology.
And there are advanced sectors
where innovation happens
and backward sectors that
there is no innovation.
And in each sector, there is an incumbent
and a potential entrance
and in the model only
potential entrance innovates.
And there is the decision
make to end invest in R and D
in order to replace the
incumbent decision made by,
in the productive sector.
And if successful
productivity in that sector
increased by some factor
and the new intron take over the market.
Otherwise the incumbent
remaining a monopolist
and productivity is given
by H and T minus one.
And we derive from the
model two key result.
One is that democracy,
when democracy increases,
when the level of democracy,
when level of competition increases,
then it's more likely for
the incumbent to be replaced.
So the key, the average growth
is given by this equation
and this is increasing in democracy
and democracy is more growth enhancing
when you are close to
the technology frontier.
So I think it's an important paper
showing value of democracy for innovation
and technological progress.
And also the value of democracy
in maintaining market competition,
market competition based on productivity,
based on the innovation, as
opposed to Political Connection.
So there are core country
evident to support this,
the clinical insight from this paper
by Aghion, Alesina and Trebbi, okay.
So there are other match mark,
beside one focusing on public investment,
the one on innovation
that are other benchmark,
we focus on redistribution,
also focus on threat of
appropriation concept enforcement
and in all these models,
political incentive
can meaningfully distort
economic outcome and welfare.
Okay, so now let's move
away from (indistinct)
benchmark to look at
the empirical questions
that we can drive derive
from these benchmark.
So the first is that how democracy
affect public investment,
how Political Connection
affect innovation,
market competition and
procurement, for instance,
and can we quantify the
GDP and welfare loss
due to those connections
and what kind of policy
can be put in place
to curb those distortion?
All right, so I'm going to start
with the Voter-Induced
Distortion, Patronage.
Directly linking decision
in public investment
to an incentive to win vote,
or win political support.
So we are going to use an
illustration of political
or a Voter-Induced Political
Distortion, patronage
the work by Burgess et al as an example,
where we look at effects
of role as (indistinct)
on co-ethnics,
depending on whether the
country has a dictatorship
or a democracy.
There are other similar
works, but the focus here
will be on that similar paper in Kenya.
So this picture shows for instance,
how road expenditure respond
to democratic breakdown.
So from 1960 to '79, you have democracy
from '79 to, I think from '70,
I'm sorry, from '70 to '80,
you have an autocracy, and
there is a leader change
in 1980, and then later
on you have democracy
with leadership change.
So you have two, first of all,
with (indistinct) breakdown
and leadership change.
And the question is
how investment in roads
or road maintenance respond
to those kind of political incentives?
And you can see from the
picture under a democracy,
there is smaller much
smaller gap between ethnics
and co-ethnics and much bigger gap
between ethnic, co-ethnic under autocracy.
So when you look at which
ethnicity is in charge,
you see that there is
even the ethnic group
that have been excluded from
power, have less investment
than the ethnic group in power,
but then the ethnic group
have never been power,
the level of road investment
does not re respond democratic breakdown.
So this map is very, very interesting
because it shows what the
roles networks have been,
if it was based on
population and market access.
And then what roadmap,
the sort of the roads are,
under democracy and autocracy.
You can see the deviation from first base,
the deviation from wash the
contractual roads network
over roads investment that the
respond to market incentives
and population it's the gap between that
and the actual network it's
smaller on the democracy
than it is on the autocracy.
So clearly democracy is better
as allocating fairly
optimally road networks.
I mean, road investment, I'm sorry.
Okay, so one another example,
I talk about public investment,
but another investment that
the government has made
is investing to protect property rights
and Goldstein and Udry have they paper
in which they show how
those in power, the chiefs
and the elites, they tend to invest more
in new technology to protect,
I mean, more productive
technology, because the fear,
they have less fear that
the asset will be sized.
That their property
rights would be respected,
and that model, they show
that lack of security
or property rights creates
distortion in investment,
where the elite can invest in following
to increase production and productivity,
and those not empower much less.
And it has an important, it
has an implication for gender,
because for instance, women
are particularly penalized,
not only because we rally hold office,
but because of gender
gap in land property.
Okay, so Sabrin Beg 2021 paper
on paternalism economic
dependency in Pakistan.
Also another dimension of distortion,
which based on the structural dependence
of rural farmers on political elites
who have them as tenants.
And in that paper, she
shows how this exchange
of protection, mitigate risks
against political support
leads to a situation where
you can create more inequality
in rural setting and only
changing agricultural technology
for instance, can undermine
this partner relationship
between the political elite and tenants.
So overall public investment,
private investment
can be distorted by unequal power,
but also by connections,
by incentive of government,
to want to selectively
serve some consistencies,
particularly co-ethnics
in the case of Kenya.
Okay, so now let's move from
Voter-Induced Distortion
from Firm-Induced Distortion,
which is commonly known as,
or commonly called Political Connection.
So, a similar paper in that
along those line is by Fisman
that shows how Suharto's
health can affect stock prices
of firms that's connected to Suharto.
And you can see the relationship here,
a negative correlation between
news about Suharto health
and stock prices.
And this Political Connection
is becoming a central,
central issue in many
developing countries.
And there is a descriptive
datasets by Faccio
showing foreign how this
common, this widespread,
this phenomena are of Political Connection
between firms and politicians.
And one implication of this connection
is the effect on
innovation using the model
that I just described you earlier
about Schumpeterian model.
So at beats and quarters
show that in Italy
firms that are more
likely to be connected,
they tend to innovate less.
And despite the fact that
connections reduce their cost
and they have supporting evidence to show
how Political Connections
reduce incentive to invest,
using RDD exploiting,
RDD on close election.
So, the key point here
is that an incumbent firm
can choose to entrench itself
in investing in Political Connection
to deter innovators entry
and industries with more
Political Connection,
have less innovation, older
firm tend to be less productive.
Okay, so far I have talked
about how Political Connection
is widespread and how firms can benefit
from those connections.
The literature, the current literature
have talked about how those
benefits can come about.
So I'll basically cover a couple of papers
that dealt with the mechanism.
One will be focused with
the evidence from Pakistan
and another one from Lithuania.
So on Pakistan, the way
Political Connection is measured
is by me board membership in private bank,
by, sorry in public bank by politicians.
And the firm with politician board member,
they receive 42% larger loans
and 50% higher default rates.
And the effect is driven
by government banks
so no private banks here.
And what is fascinating in that paper
is that the preferential treatments
increases with political strength,
measured by the victory
margin of the politician
in an election, and also by
the level of participation,
electoral participation in the district
where the politician is running.
And we also measured the GDP
loss due to this distortion
and we find, for instance, that
the lower bound of one to 15
to 103 GDP loss, and the high estimates,
an addition one, 1.6%.
So you can see how Political Connection
affect the economy as a
whole in terms of GDP loss.
So another effect of Political Connection
is too, procurement.
And there is a very
interesting paper in 2012,
covering the campaign contribution ban
that was implement in
Lithuania in 2012 and the show,
the building behavior, the
contrary building behavior
of firms that made campaign contribution,
versus those who did not
make campaign contribution,
you can see before the
ban that takes place here,
the bidding behavior were very different,
but then it converged after the ban.
So it shows that Political Connection,
but with campaign
contribution has strong effect
on building behavior, okay.
So other works covering
probability of bailouts,
loan from state bank, lower taxation,
easier, easier access to import licenses,
the grocery captures
and so on and so forth.
So I think a major
challenge to development
come from Political Connection,
and there is a wide trend
of evidence to support that.
So now let's move to State Capture.
It's a case where this are
systemic and entrenched,
where there is some
kind of distortion trap,
even when there is competitive elections.
So we call this situation
a chronic capitalism,
which is very, very common
in countries that have legacy
or developmental states like
in Asia and North Africa,
but also currently in Russia
and many Eastern European countries.
Okay, so one important
area of State Capture
is International Corporations
that basically, through, one of pressure
by domestic governments and
even sometime have a power
to appoint ministers,
particular ministry of finance.
This was a case in Togo, Guinea
and this has also been
the case in South Africa.
So, one interesting
dimension of State Capture
is the ability of firms
to use different form of State Capture.
Direct form of State Capture,
where the firms work with bureaucrats
to implement distortion,
like favorable tax rates
or rigging procurement,
or they can also use
indirect form of set capture,
which is they control
politicians to campaign donation,
and then the politician control
what the bureaucrats would do.
And what we found in this paper
is that when the electro
processes is competitive
firm use direct form of
State Capture as an insurance
against potential loss,
due to the fact that the
politician that they support
will be out of power.
And we find evidence that
when we winning margin
in local elections in Benin increases,
the form of State Capture
that the firms use is direct.
They tend to go after bureaucrats
who have longer tenure in
office than politicians.
And what is interesting
is that the resolve this correlation,
this correlation between
formal State Capture
and competition, electoral competition
is presence in municipal election,
not in legislative elections,
as you can see here,
because alleged elections,
I mean, MP do not control bureaucrats.
They don't have control bureaucracy.
They don't have any direct
connection with bureaucracy.
And we use a placebo, the winning margin
between the second and the third runner
in the local elections, and
we find no effect, okay.
So, what this shows in a very powerful way
is that even in competitive elections,
you can still see distortion
because politician will switch
from one form to another.
And if this is the case, it shows that,
first, distortion might
be, might still be present
with increased electoral competition,
but also with improved
bureaucrat selection
and in the model, and also
in the empirical areas
that we have done, we show
that distortion decreases
when you have improved
politician selection.
So, sometimes democracy works
in curving Political Distortion,
sometime it doesn't particularly
when firms have access
directly to bureaucrats,
if bureaucratic capture is possible.
So in that case, political
selection is key.
You need to go after, we need the process,
to generate politicians that
are not connected to firms.
And you can generate
some internal competition
in political parties, the
process, you can also courage
for instance grassroot mobilization.
And you can use many
strategies for instance,
to be able to detect and to
isolate connected politicians.
And that way the political selection
can lead to a decrease
in Political Distortion.
Okay, now let me let's now finish
by discussing how you deal with it.
And I think this is clearly
my favorite part of a talk,
because what I've shown so far
is that growth is political,
state capacity and the political process
play an important role.
So, political economy should
be less backward looking
in terms of trying to find out
how historical institutions
affect growth today,
what to be more prospective
and prescriptive.
The version of political economy
that I think could make the
best contribution to growth
is the one that deals not
only with what to be done,
but how this could be done.
And there is a growing
literature try to deal with that,
starting for instance,
with banning, lobbying,
I mean, limiting lobbying,
banning income company
contribution, limiting the extent
to which firms can basically
support financially
political campaign in many countries.
And there are a lot of laws
across Africa and Latin America
to deal with these issues,
so that's clearly progress.
But then there is a growing
literature on public management,
and it's about audit and
government contract, for instance,
and taxes, monitoring that
disclosed losses to consumer
given political agent behavior
and anticipation of disclosure
that potentially cause police
to shift public investment.
So increased transparency
is very important.
It's something that can be done,
and it has proven to be very effective.
Another is technology,
that works on ID cards,
digital collection of
taxes, E invoicing, voting
and regulatory reform, public humans work,
overall, it's proven a
very promising avenue
to reduce distortion.
And as I said earlier, "A key
to Chinese economic growth
is not only the politics that
creates some sort of consensus
among the elite about growth."
It's also about decentralized,
sorry, decentralization,
public management, policy
explanation, those state reform,
public management reforms,
that in fact has a very, very
important effect on growth.
Now the second is political selection.
So, there are massive literature
on how providing
information during election,
before election can help,
can affect voting behavior.
And there are a lot of focus
on the type of information,
type of campaign promises that
will affect voting behavior,
or the incentives of politician
to do the right thing,
to make the right level
of public investment.
But overall, the evidence is mixed.
And I think in my view,
it's not about whether
information works or not.
It's what type of information,
under what conditions
information should be effective.
And it depend on the
relevance of the information.
It all depend on the
power that (indistinct)
have to act on the information.
So it's important to consider
the institutional setting
of the information when
information is provided
so that we can make information provision
as a way to improve transparency
and accountability in government.
So, political selection is not just demand
for good type of politician,
but also supply of good
type of politicians.
There are recent work, for instance,
trying to create environments
where good politician development
promoting politician will emerge.
There is tongue (indistinct)
policy deliberation
during campaigns for instance,
can help kind of clean up to some degree,
have a political process,
and also primaries in which
citizens have some say
into who will run for
office for different parties
can also help us select better politicians
or motivating politicians
by incentivizing the personal justice,
the social value of running for election,
how this can actually help this.
And one interesting paper
shows that when this election
process happen publicly,
the public pressure can get
politicians to actually,
I mean, better politician,
development promoting politician,
to arise.
Now, one important Political Distortion
is lack of representation,
particular gender representation,
for obvious reasons.
So all the work on gender
quarter on incentives
provide incentive for
women to run for office
are also a part of political selection,
more representative political process.
So this is critical.
Now let me finish by talking
about what I call public reason
and social contract.
It's an ambitious kind of concept
developed by political philosophers,
particularly by Macedo, my
colleague from Princeton
that states that the liberal
ideal or popular reason
hold that those advocating
for law and policies
ought to offer adequate
reason that could be shared
by all reasonable members of the community
is the idea that policy should be based
first on evidence on reason.
And those reasons has to be made public
and has to aim at getting
reasonable individual
to agree.
And I think it's such a powerful concept
for the discussion debates on
reducing Political Distortion,
because the technical part
of Political Distortion,
which is we discussed by
say public management,
the fact that political
selection is not enough
because of one piece which is
missing political selection
perhaps is public reason
and social contract.
So that's why the evidence
on participatory governance,
I mean Litrature on participatory
governance is important,
but unfortunately, even there,
the result had been mixed.
And the reason why it's mixed in my view,
it's because of a design.
And also because sometime it's
public, not enough reason,
so it's not enough to get
people in the room to debate.
You need the debate to be
anchored by evidence, by logic.
You also need as a goal
to get people to agree,
to get people to commit.
And so this is the logic behind a project
that I'm currently conducting in Nigeria,
very ambitious for where
we have an intervention
in several states.
And that intervention had three steps,
the first steps is information
gathering and dissemination
on policy preferences,
deliberation through what
we call education summit
and the drafting of a social contract.
So if I can show you what it looks like.
So basically the question in that project
is to look at the effect
of that intervention
I don't describe on policy
design and priorities,
stakeholder buying investment in reform,
and looking at two set of mechanism.
One is information, and the
other one is empowerment.
So the project timeline look like this.
So there is a summit,
whether it's policy dialogue
before the summit data
collection and post summit,
ensuring that everyone
basically have a minimum
understanding of what need to be done.
So those are pictures, for
instance, from "The Summit,"
you have a (indistinct) of government
and basically teachers
and parents, and so on.
And one full day discussion
anchored by solid,
by survey on priorities on
government budget and so on,
led to a contract, now some
kind of written agreement
of what education should look like
and what should be the
role and what should be,
what commitment we want
each stakeholders to have.
And after that, the
governments serve a work plan
that responded to what people want
and what people basically
decided at the meeting.
And then there have been follow
up to have also a commitment
from other side from parents,
so the government, okay.
The policy deliberation led
to commitment by government
at school level, parents,
teachers are informed.
They also make commitment
in a written contract,
but let me just finish
by telling a little bit
about what we learn from this.
First, I think that states,
(indistinct chattering)
oh, where is it?
Okay, let's do that.
Yeah, that's good, thank you.
All right, that's perfect.
Yeah, thanks very much.
So first, one weakness
of this old exercise here
is the lack of flexible growth model
that really integrate different
aspects of institutions,
which is public investment
contract enforcement and so on.
Instead of having separate model,
one dealing with innovation
and market competition,
another one dealing with public investment
might be interesting to
build a coherent model
that cover different aspects.
We also need to pay more
attention to the systematic,
(indistinct) the systemic
Political Distortion
that we call crony capitalism,
which is really a big issue
in many, many countries,
in the developing world.
But in some, I'm proposing
here is political economy
to be more prescriptive, more prospective.
There is focus on
institutional experimentation,
not only experimenting with different ways
of improve public management,
improve political selection,
improve citizens engagement,
so that Political
Distortion can be reduced.
An important point as well that I develop
is the idea that we need to
define Political Distortion.
Defining measuring Political
Distortion has to be key,
has to be the starting point
of political economic research.
That means we need to know
what things ought to be
like in the model that I discuss,
or for instance, in the work that Jr
and his cohort have done in Kenya,
and then have a clear
understanding of the distortion
of what things ought to be,
and then think it about
institutional innovation.
And this can be through
some different form
of experimentation to reduce
the Political Distortion.
So overall, I think political
economy can be a powerful tool
for development, because
as we said earlier,
"States and government
good or bad government
account for perhaps 50%
of development outcome."
So there is an important
role for government to play,
but to do that, it
shouldn't be just describing
what government does, is
to identifying departure
from what government is doing
from what they ought to be doing,
and then find ways to reduce distortion
that are generated by the process.
Thank you very much.
(audience clapping)
- You want to manage your questions?
- Yeah.
- So I think we have
some time for questions.
If you have questions, then
Boomy has a mic up there.
So if you just raise your
hand, she will come to you.
(indistinct chatter)
- [Woman 1] Hi, thank you so
much for a wonderful lecture.
One of the questions I had was,
do you think that the
socially optimum level
of Political Connections
ought to be near zero,
or are there cases or conditions
under which Political Connections
might actually stand in
for a lack of information
or lack of state capacity?
So for example, when there
are development initiatives
being undertaken, there is a greater move
towards engaging people who
have local level information.
And those are people
who are generally politically connected.
And so when you say that
we should have models
that point towards an endogenous level
of socially optimum Political Connections,
would those be positive
under certain conditions?
Thank you.
- Yeah, the short is yes.
So basically, Political
Connection is (indistinct)-
- [Man 1] Put on the mic.
- Oh sorry.
We need to think about non
stationary Political Connection,
for instance, bringing
private sector expertise
in regulation in policy making,
but you have to be careful
about conflict of interest.
You have to be careful about,
attempt by firms to block entry and so on.
So I think private and public partnerships
can be non stationary
and political process exactly as you said,
can be informed or can be improved
by some type of connection
with private sector,
but we need to find creative
way to reduce stationary,
private connection,
like when we described.
- [Instructor] Thank you for that.
Any other questions from the audience?
- [Woman 2] Thank you so much for that
very insightful lecture.
I had one question on how you
might maybe not integrate,
but bring in some of discussion
around the role of the free press,
which I think he's written so much about
in creating the right kinds of
public engagement strategies?
- Yeah, I think that's a
very, very important point.
I think the press even social media
can help amplify transparency,
can also amplify citizens engagement,
but I strongly believe that at the start,
the reason important the reason
is as important as public.
It means that discussion
about public policy,
discussion about not only
institutional design,
it has to be first based on evidence.
It has to be first based on some research,
so that you can actually constrain
the extent to which you
can have misinformation,
or you can have the
press freedom being used
to actually increase distortion,
because taking advantage of how vulnerable
some populations are, some vulnerable,
some segment society are,
this press can be used
in fact, to enhance the interest
of some special interest.
I mean, of a government
or some special interest.
So yes, the press and freedom
is very, very important,
but I think that evidence, research
to support healthy debate discussions
it's really, really,
really important, so, yes.
So I will see the word by as very in line
with this idea of
promoting to transparency,
I mean, political engagement,
ownership of policies,
empowerment, all those concepts
that we think have value
in reducing distortion,
the press can play a role
in amplifying that.
But I think there is,
I mean, my initial kind of sense is that,
debate, discussions, engagement
supported by serious
evidence and by research,
that's really, really, really critical.
Yeah.
Thank you.
- [Woman 3] Thank you.
We are live streaming and
there are a number of questions
that came up on the zoom,
so I just wanna take the
chance to ask one of those.
So this one concerned your
findings for (indistinct)
and it asks, do your
findings apply to developed
as well as developing countries?
And if so, would there
be any complications
for developing countries
seeking to implement
these solutions that you propose
if developed countries don't
also make the same changes?
- I'm sorry, I didn't understand.
- [Woman 2] So it's asking about
whether your findings apply
to developed as well as
developing countries.
And if so, would there
be any complications
if developing countries
are looking to implement
the kind of solutions you're proposing,
if developed countries don't
also make those changes?
- I'm not sure if I
understand the last part
of the question.
If develop countries
implement the same change,
will it be possible to do it
in the developing countries.
- [Woman 3] As in if developing countries
want to make those changes,
would there be any problems
if developed countries don't also seek
to make those changes as well?
- I mean, I'm not sure
if I understand the question properly,
but obviously distortions
are sometime international.
Like France, US corporations
might be the one capturing
domestic governments.
The case of the Gupta
brothers in South Africa,
it's a good one.
So the solution that we are proposing,
shouldn't be just about
developing countries.
It should also be about
developed countries
and their relationship
with developing countries.
You have to hold, you need transparency,
not only domestically, but
also trans internationally.
And you need, for instance
governments of France and US
to hold their corporation accountable,
the way they have to deal with governments
in developing countries.
we have several law that
penalized attempt to bribe
foreign governments to basically
to limit State Capture.
And I know for instance
(indistinct) in France
had some legal issues
related to his dealing
in Togo and Guinea.
So those are, I think it's
linking domestic reform
in the international system.
It's something which will
be really, really important.
Having said that,
I think that there have been
in many developed countries,
progress in regulation, in law
against conflict of interests
or there are long experience
in public management
at all level that we can learn from
that we can try to apply
similar kind of principle
in trying to reform states
in developing countries.
So two things, so first
there are lesson learned
from the US, from France and
other advanced democracies
that can be very helpful
in dealing with poor Political Distortion
in developing countries, that's one.
Second I agree that finding,
you have to deal not only
with distortion domestically,
but to deal with foreign
induced distortion
at domestic level.
The Gupta brothers in South
Africa is a good example.
So you need an international system
not such a domestic system,
that help deal with Political Distortion.
- [Instructor] Any
questions in the audience,
particularly on that side,
we can bring the mic over.
- [Man 2] Hi, very comprehensive
talk and highly relevant.
I wanna go back to your
notes on trumpeter,
and corruption and political action.
It can be motivated fundamentally
by fear or opportunism.
When it's motivated by
fear, there's fear of loss
and the loss to the actor can
to be measured in dollars,
but the cost is measured
in percentage of GDP.
Have you done any work or seen any work
having thoughts on how that
action can be mitigated
because the cost so far outweighs the loss
to the actors that are bringing
down the entire system?
Thank you.
- So maybe, can you,
maybe for me to understand
the question better, can
you give a specific example,
for instance (indistinct).
- [Man 2] I could think in
terms of the energy sector maybe
that there are actors
in coal, for example,
that they are lobbying
very hard to prevent action
on more progressive,
more beneficial alternative energy
that if implemented, we
would have cleaner air,
cleaner water, maybe cheaper energy
overall in the long term,
but in the shear model,
they're holding everything back.
So we don't have progress
and the innovation
that otherwise could have
to the benefit to GDP.
- Yeah.
So, I think that's a
very, very interesting
and very complicated question.
Okay, the one perhaps way I
can think about this issue
is some type of government
subsidy for this emerging sector
to be able to compete
effectively from the old,
but backward (indistinct) the streets,
the destructive sector might be important,
but then how do you put in
place with political incentives
for more forward looking governments
willing to stand against
this kind of very powerful,
economic interests in
favor of a status quo.
So it's a very, I think the it's a,
I think what's currently
happening is I don't know,
like public debates on novel
energy, climate change.
And you expect perhaps that public opinion
will help sway politicians
in favor of these solutions
that might not be in the short
term politically beneficial.
But I think the more I think about it,
the more I realize how social movement,
grassroot mobilization for
instance has great value,
in pushing you see what I mean,
like in pushing governments
to deal with those kind of tough issues,
because the way you can deal
with the issue you talk about
can all be some bottom up
mobilization, grassroots,
that would perhaps lead to the
emergence of more progressive
politician willing to
take on those policies
because they know they
have popular support
because they know that the international
and domestic movement and support
of those kind of policies.
So maybe one way to counter
balance the status quo,
besides science, it could also be,
like grassroot mobilization,
and I think grassroot mobilization has,
can have economic value,
especially when the sector
that the progressive sector
that you said do not
have the political clouds
and the resources to compete against,
so you can think of a (indistinct) model
where the curbing
distortion and (indistinct),
and it would include political selection
that requires a very strong
grassroots popular movement,
and I think the current
climate change consistency
that may not have been, that
have some little support
from the green energy
sector, but is very powerful,
very vocal, young.
It could be a good way
to balance the incentives
that lead to this innovation,
this progress, the impossible.
So my immediate answer
to your question will be,
let's go to the people,
let's get them to revolt.
(laughing)
Let's get them to speak out
loudly, vocalize young people,
get them to yell at whatever
then maybe something is possible.
So I'm going back to my days in the '80s,
where I thought that you,
when nothing is possible,
get young people on the
streets and perhaps,
we can be the balance.
We can provide the support
that you need for progress.
So I think that's what I would say.
I mean, if you look at,
in the '70s and '80s,
It's not about climate change, not about
but it was in the best
interests of powerful elites
to maintain the status quo,
oppressive anti-freedom and so on.
And we have support from
international corporations,
from US and France and so on,
look at Chile, but then you
have popular mobilization,
student movement and student unions
that provided the support needed
for the emergence of an
alternative political elite
that made political
change, democratization,
democracy possible because
I mean, it was not clear
from the beginning that democratization
was economically rational.
Given that many countries
in the west were supportive
of autocrats so that they can
control naturals resources
and this kind of stuff.
But then you have the
counter balance coming
from social movement that help democracy,
to arise in these countries.
So it's a very complex
question, I think on the spot
that's what I can say, thank you.
- [Instructor] I think
that's a really good segue
into question that we've just
gotten through on the zoom.
So this is asking, are
you concerned at all
by Political Distortions, by big tech,
since they can influence people's actions
at a grassroots level via smartphone?
- I'm sorry.
- [Woman 4] So are you concerned
about Political Distortions
by big tech firms?
So I guess Facebook, Twitter, and so on,
as it influence how people
act at a Grassroot level
using their smartphones.
- So big tech can do what?
I'm sorry.
- [Instructor] Sorry.
Can influence people's politics.
It can influence how
people are viewing politics
using their smartphone.
- Wow, that's a very interesting question.
For instance, if we think that
public reason is a way to go
and technology can amplify
basically what people,
I mean, can shape what people think.
Can it be in the best
interest of tech company
not to serve the public as a whole,
but serve our own interest.
So yeah, I think it just confirm
why we also need relation
with tech sector so that we can remain,
so that we can make the tech sector
as politically neutral as possible.
We can prevent, like for instance,
if you look at what's
happened with Facebook,
that was in their interest
to distort information
so that they can sell, so
there is a rising interest
in regulating social
media and tech companies,
and I think this will be,
I think this would one way for
me to answer this question,
by saying, for instance
that tech companies
might not necessarily act
in the of the general public,
in the interest of economic
development and progress,
they might have some other incentives.
So regulation of this
is necessary to protect
basically to protect the political process
against extremism,
against divisive discourse
and so on and so forth.
So that's my initial
reaction to the question.
- [Instructor] Okay, thank you.
We've got time for one
more audience question.
- [Man 3] Thank you very much professor.#
In your lecture, you
mentioned how co-ethnic
as well as competition
affect Political Distortion,
but you didn't mention ideology.
And I was wondering whether
there has been any research
into the ideology of political parties
and how that affects the
level of Political Distortion
in a state.
- No, I think that's a great question.
Ideology can act as
ethnicity, there is a parallel
between basically ethnic identity
and ideological identity.
I mean, identity based on ideologies,
and so in the US, for instance,
very polarized politics,
obviously you have racial
division but then the gap
between Republican and
Democrats shaped by in part
can be as destructive
can be as distortionary
as ethnic divisions.
And so, yeah, I will
say in some countries,
what we call ethnicity could be religion,
in other countries could be ideology.
It sometimes it could be even be regions
and entrenched interest
that's a originally based
that creates this
distortion, distortion exists
so long as one party
find its best interest
to serve that group at the
expense of other groups.
So I think that's what I can say.
So, lemme put this way and I
think that one of the concern
that some philosopher
have about public reason
is the fact that in polarized societies
it will not lead to consensus,
but lead to maybe more division.
And the argument that the
political theories make
is that even in a polarized society,
it's worth trying to build a consensus,
even if you achieve it or not.
It's worth trying to find
reasons for us to work together,
to find reasons why we
should be less divided,
and if the reason exists
and you are patient enough,
then you can overcome those divisions.
So, the point here is that ideologies,
ideological differences
act like ethnic differences
in many contexts,
but even then there must
be institutional setting.
There must be institutional innovation
that try to bridge the divides.
And one key element I think
is putting forward the needs
for collaboration, the need
for consensus building,
whether this works in
the short term or not,
and I think anyway, so
that's what I can say.
So I think I agree with you
entirely but I think that,
but there is a solution.
It can be institutional,
there's maybe one last question,
if you don't mind.
Yes.
- [Woman 4] (indistinct)
out of time but maybe.
(indistinct chattering)
Yeah, please go ahead, (indistinct)
(laughing)
That's a very powerful.
(indistinct chattering)
(laughing)
- Yes my name is Sarah Caremi.
I am a film director from Afghanistan.
I am just visiting (indistinct)
like visiting small professor
and also visiting for maker here
from very far of Afghanistan.
But accidentally, I just
entered to your class
because we are preparing for
this screening of my film
and I just catch few, few sentences.
I would like to ask Mr. Professor that
I am come from this country,
that unfortunately we
have many, many problems.
Like we have problems, ethical problems.
We have problems, political problems,
and everything is so complicated.
And America, 20 years ago came to country
with this big slogan that we
are going to solve your issues.
We are going to motivate you to be United.
We are going to save your country
because you have many, many issues.
And during last 20 years, we
were practicing being United
and my generation, we were quite good,
and we were very, very active participant.
And today I am in America and I am here,
I am showcasing my films.
I am showcasing those
achievements that we achieved
during past 20 years in a country
that somehow signed a peace
deal with the most terror group
in the world with the most
ideologist group in the world
with the most pro ethnic
group in the world
and somehow by this
still, they divided us.
They divided my generation,
they divided my country.
They put new, new and very
old conflict between us.
What do you think about the
policy America about us,
about my country and many countries
that America is now trying to divide it?
Thank you.
- So I have, I'm tempted to say
that's a very, very complicated question,
which is a bit above my pedigree.
All I can say is that I wish
the best for Afghanistan
and for all the countries that
have similar set of issues
and as a research
community, I'm pretty sure
we have to contribute to thinking
about how could Afghanistan
have been dealt with differently.
So I think Roger Meison
has a paper on that
using the experience of British
colonialism indirect rule,
by saying maybe there was a better way
to deal with the country, I don't know.
So the point of
(indistinct) open question.
So I feel sorry that it's what it is,
but hopefully we can get
out of the current crisis.
Thank you.
- And please join me and thanking Leonard
for a fantastic lecture.
Thank you very much.
(audience clapping)